what i want to do in this video is think
about exponents in a slightly different
way that will be useful for different
contexts and also go through a lot more
examples so in the last video we saw
that taking something to an exponent
means multiplying that number that many
times so if i had the number negative
two
and i want to raise it to the third
power this literally means taking three
negative twos so this literally means
taking three negative two so negative
two
negative two and negative 2 and then
multiplying them
and then
multiplying them so what's this going to
be well let's see negative 2 times
negative 2 is positive 4
and then positive 4 times negative two
is negative eight so this would be equal
to
this would be equal to
negative eight
now another way of thinking about
exponents instead of saying you're just
taking three negative twos and
multiplying and this is a completely
reasonable way of viewing it you could
also view it as this is the this is the
number of times you're going to multiply
this number times 1. so you could
completely view this as being equal to
so you're going to start with a 1 and
you're going to multiply 1
times negative 2 3 times
so
this is times
negative 2
times negative 2
times
times negative 2. so clearly these are
the same number here we just took this
and we're just multiplying it by one so
you're still you're still going to get
negative eight
and this might be a slightly more useful
idea to to get an intuition for
exponents especially when you start
taking things to the one or zero power
so let's think about that a little bit
what is
what is positive 2
to the
based on this definition to the zero
power going to be equal to
to the zero power going to be equal to
well we just said this says how many
times are you going to multiply 1 times
this number so this literally says i'm
going to take a 1
i'm going to take a 1 and i'm going to
multiply it by 2 0 times well if i'm
going to multiply it by 2 0 times that
means i'm just left with the 1. so 2 to
the 0 power is going to be equal to 1.
and actually any nonzero number to the 0
power is one by that same rationale and
i'll make another video that will also
give a little bit more intuition on
there that might seem very
counter-intuitive but it's based on one
way of thinking about it is thinking of
an exponent as this and this will also
make sense if we start thinking of what
2 to the first power is
so 2
2 to the first power so let's go to this
this definition we just gave of the
exponent we always start with a 1
and we multiply it by the two
one time
so two is going to be one we're only
going to multiply it by the two i'll use
this for multiplication i'll use a dot
we're going to multiply it by two one
time
so one times two well that's clearly
just going to be equal to 2
and any number to the first power is
just going to be equal to that number
and then we can go from there and you'll
of course see the pattern if we say what
squared is 2 squared
well based on this definition we start
with a 1
and we multiply it by 2
2 times
so times 2
times 2 is going to be equal to four
and we've seen this before you go to two
to the third
two to the third power
you start with a one
start with a one and then multiply it by
two three times
so times two times two times two
this is going to give us positive
positive eight and you probably see a
pattern here every time we multiply by
two or every time i should say we raise
2 to a 1 more power we are multiplying
by 2. notice this you to go from 2 to
the 0 to the 1 we multiplied we
multiplied by 2. i'll use a little x for
the multiplication symbol now the little
cross
and then to go from 2 to the first power
to 2 to the second power we multiply by
multiply by 2 again and that makes
complete sense because this is literally
telling us how many times are we going
to take this number and how many times
i'm going to take one and multiply it by
this number and so when you go from two
to the second part of to the third
you're multiplying by two multiplying by
two one more time and this is another
intuition of why something to the zero
power is equal to 1. if you were to go
backwards if say we didn't know what 2
to the 0 power is and we were just
trying to figure out what would make
sense when we go from 2 to the third
part of 2 to the second we'd be dividing
by 2 we're going from 8 to 4 then we
divide by 2 again to go from 2 to the
second to 2 to the first and then maybe
it seems like we should just divide by 2
again for from going from 2 to the first
to 2 to the 0 and that would give us 1.